الى اخر تطورات حرب روسيا لاوكرانيا اذ
نفت كيف اي علاقه لها بالاحداث في منطقه
الروسيه واقل المتحدث باسم المخابرات
الاوكرانيه اندريوس ان فيلقين روسيين
معارضين ينفذين عمليه داخل المقاطعه
لانشاء ما سماها منطقه امنيه لحمايه
المدنيين الاوكرانيين
اعلنت سلطات الاوكرانيه عن قصف روسي مكثف
على قرى المقاطعه المتاخمه
ذلك اعلن حاكم مقاطعه بيلجورد الروسيه ان
الدفاعات الجويه اسقطت طائره مسيره دون ان
يؤدي ذلك الى اضرارنا وخسائر واضاف انه تم
رصده هجمات بمسيرات ومستمرون بعملياتها
التنشيط بعد تسلل مجموعه تخريب اوكرانيه
لمتابعه تنضم اليها من دونيت كمراسله
الجزيره كارمن جوخادار مرحبا
كارمن ما الذي يحدث في بيل جورود بحسب
الروايه الروسيه بالتاكيد
نعم ما يجري في بالقر التفصيل مهم للغايه
هذا ليس الاول عند المناطق الحدوديه ومن
اذا ما راقبنا ما جرى يوم امس استهداف
لمناطق ثلاث عند الحدود الروسيه
الاوكرانيه
هذا الاستهداف ليس الاول في مارس الماضي
محمد جرى الحديث عن خليه تسللت الى منطقه
وقامت باسر بعض الاشخاص وتم تصفيتها في
النهايه هذا الحادث تكرر في منطقه بالغرد
التي تقع على الحدود الروسيه الاوكرانيه
نحن غطينا العام الماضي في بالغرد وبقينا
فتره في تلك المقاطعه التي تقع على الحدود
هذه المنطقه تشكل اهميه استراتيجيه للقوات
الروسيه اذ انها كانت تشكل خزانا لوجستيا
للقوات التي كانت تتواجد حينها في مقاطعه
خاركف الاوكرانيه اليوم
وما تحدثت عنه السلطات هو ان مجموعه
وصفتهم بالمخربين تسللوا الى هذه المدينه
الى هذه المقاطعه وحصلت اشتباكات وتقوم
السلطات المعنيه وقوات القوات الروسيه
بالتعامل مع هؤلاء ما جرى وفق حاكم
المقاطعه باستشلاب جلاتكوف قال ان امراه
قتلت واصيب عشرات اشخاص في هذه الاحداث
المتطوره في المقاطعه هذه المقاطعه شهدت
يوم امس قصفا اوكرانيا وفقه الحاكم هو ادى
الى جرح هؤلاء الاشخاص ما يجري في بلجرود
مستمر لغايه الان هناك ايضا تفصيل مهم
للغايه اعلنه يوم امس الحاكم باجراءات
مرتبطه بنقل هذه المقاطعه الى مقاطعه يتم
التعامل فيها مع مستوى الارهاب اجراءات
عده منها وقف المدارس والتعليم عن بعد
بدات اليوم ايضا وقف كل الانشطه المرتبطه
بمواد قد تتصل او يمكن ان تؤدي الى
استخدامها في اعمال ارهابيه اعلان الحاكم
وايضا التتبع التثبت من الهويات اذا
استمعنا الى الروايه الروسيه فيما يتعلق
بما يحدث في انضم الينا الان وراسلونا
تامر الصمادي من ميكولايف تامر ما الذي
تقوله الروايه الاوكرانيه
صباح الخير محمد الروايه الاوكرانيه تتحدث
عن هجوم متواصل داخل بيل جرود ليس لها اي
علاقه به وذلك على لسان المخابرات
الاوكرانيه المتحدث باسم المخابرات
الاوكرانيه تحدث عن مجموعه او مجموعتين
مواليتين لاوكرانيا وقال بان عناصر
المجموعه الاولى وهي حريه روسيا او كما
تسمى بحريه روسيا بالاضافه الى
المجموعه الاخرى وهي للمتطوعين الذين
خدموا سابقا في القوات الروسيه
يقومون بعمليات داخل ويعملون على السيطره
على عدد من المواقع وعلى عدد من الاماكن
والحديد طيله ساعات فجر اليوم عن استهداف
للمقر الحكوميه داخل المدينه وفي الحقيقه
بثت العديد من المقاطع المصوره على صفحات
تيليجرام موا
الحديث يجري في سومي عن اكثر من 20
انفجارا وقصفا المعارك نهايه محمد تتواصل
ايضا بين القوات الاوكرانيه والروسيه في
باخموت وفقا لهيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه
والحديث هنا عن المقاطعات الجنوبيه عن قصف
لا يهدا لا يتوقف لا سيما في خرسون في
زبروجيا شكرا لتامر الصمادي من نيكولايف
شكرا لكارمن جوخادار من دوني